there is still no winner in the u.s
election but
there are some encouraging signs for
democratic challenger joe biden
the former vice president has picked up
wins in some closely fought states
president trump meanwhile is facing an
increasingly difficult path to win
re-election he's
launched legal challenges aimed to stop
vote counting in several tight races
a call echoed by his supporters
in arizona a group of trump supporters
have been gathering to protest the
ongoing vote counting there
that race is neck and neck though
several news outlets have reported joe
biden
has flipped the battleground state trump
has made unfounded allegations of voter
fraud and on wednesday accuse democrats
of trying
to steal the election
so here's a look at the results so far
with some
closer attention given to states that
have yet to declare
a winter winner our figure showed biden
currently
on 264 and president trump on 214
that puts joe biden just six electoral
college votes away
from the 270 needed to win the
presidency
wisconsin has become the latest state to
fall into the biden column its 10
electoral votes which trump won
in the last election now go to his
democratic challenger
that brings us to nevada which has
exactly the six votes
that are on offer that biden needs for
the white house he
currently has a slim edge in that state
in georgia meanwhile 16 electoral votes
are on the table with trump leading the
way
but his margin has narrowed in the state
the trump campaign has filed a lawsuit
alleging that ineligible late absentee
ballots may have been
added to the count pennsylvania
is the biggest prize still up for grabs
with 20 electoral votes
the president currently holds a narrow
lead there but again remaining
mail ballots are expected to favor the
democrats
well the wire service ap which is our
main source for election data shows
biden has taken
arizona but some other major news
agencies have not yet called that state
so there's still
a bit of a question mark there
now the bottom line at this point
vote counting is still underway but the
path to victory appears to have narrowed
for president trump
let's get a live update from washington
now our chief political editor mikhail
kupner is standing by there
michaela boats are still being counted
are things any clearer now than they
were 24 hours ago
well we're clearly seeing a tendency
that joe biden
is actually at least narrowing the
margin
where donald trump is ahead in several
contested states although it still does
remain
a nail-biter and with many networks not
having called
arizona yet the focus is on
georgia and arizona as the potential
ticket to reach 270 for joe biden
that also explains why joe biden came
out
earlier today and said he was confident
that he would
win on the other hand we're seeing
trump's camp basically file several
lawsuits
which a republican legal expert on
national television here has
referred to as hail mary lawsuits
meaning that when a candidate realizes
that it's getting very
tight this could be a tactic not just to
win
a suit over individual ballast but to
potentially delay
um results being declared which could
then
change the whole process unless that
lawsuit
can be resolved by the time the
electoral college gathers
on the 14th of december so there's still
a couple of legal aces potentially
up donald trump's sleeve but behind
closed doors you can already
hear from republicans that they're
they're not for it this is clearly
something that donald trump wants to
push ahead with and he's clearly on the
defensive here
yesterday michaela the discussion was
very much about midwestern
states today the focus is more diffuse
we're looking at states like georgia
what's the situation there
yes because all of a sudden um joe biden
looks like he's the first one
in many years to get a chance to turn
georgia the democrat way and throughout
even
this night we've seen that initial
margin
where trump was leading melt away from
some 33
000 votes ahead to some 23
000 and we're expecting uh fresh data to
come
out of georgia um throughout this night
at some stage and that could very well
seal um the presidency for joe biden
or it would signal that yes donald trump
still has a mathematical pathway to
remain
president what are we to make of the
trump campaign
claiming voter fraud in the counting
process etc
is the voting system in the us not
considered
very reliable
well he certainly has himself stated
several times that
he doesn't believe in it he said on
pennsylvania
which has 20 electoral college votes
that he thinks
very bad things are happening there i
had the chance to actually
ask the head of the election observer
mission the international observer
mission
here in the united states of her
assessment her team's assessment of the
elections here
he in his statements he has undermined
the voter's confidence
in the electoral process that is a fact
we have that on record
and the challenges that are faced here
in the united states
is rebuilding that trust in the system
hopefully
the work that we've been doing here very
fact based will also
serve in some measure to
reassure people that how this election
actually was conducted
and that we did not find systemic
evidence of wrongdoing
he was um she was stating there that
donald trump
is at least partly to blame for many
people
having their trust in the system
undermined here and that also is quite
clear
from the written statement that came out
at the same time
the international observers gave the
electoral
system and how it was run throughout
these elections including the
very high level of transparency top
marks
so donald trump really will have to put
in some effort to push forward with that
narrative
to undermine confidence here kendall
thank you very much that was
dw's mikhailakov now in washington
so how are americans coping with this
uncertainty
now reporters went out on the streets of
washington d.c
to gauge the mood today
is a very tense day for many americans i
i believe personally as a republican
that trump won in a landslide
but because of covin and the ballots
that 300 000 ballots overnight were
found
in every city in the swing states for
biden i think
that the elections are just another
reminder about how divided
the country is right now it's remarkable
that
you know almost half of americans think
that donald trump
is the single worst person to be
president and the other half think that
he's the single best person to be
president
i'm just overwhelmed i am so stressed
out yesterday
it was like you know anxiety but today
this morning i broke down and cried
because
of the possibility that trump might be
in office again
my mom was saying earlier she feels
really misled by the polls
i'm not really up to feeling angry at
anyone
i'm just feeling sad
well u.s voters they're commenting on
the unclear outcome of
tuesday's ballot uh dw's peter leda has
been
following this election from the
beginning peter many people were
concerned
uh going into this election that there
could be unrest
uh if the vote count wasn't clear or if
it's
contested well it's the vote count is
not really clear it seems
seems to be contested are we seeing any
unrest well we definitely saw you know a
lot of preparations for that
a lot of cities boarding up more or less
in anticipation of
you know violent clashes we didn't
really see a lot of that yesterday in
the
immediate wake of the election results
coming in
but as the race has gotten tighter we
are seeing to see pockets
of if not unrest at least you know
increasing tension protest outside
several election centers in michigan we
saw a pro-trump supporters
uh crowd an election center there right
here in arizona uh what we're seeing
here in maricopa county where we're
expecting
um new results any minute now uh we've
seen trump supporters uh
essentially gathering there for for
hours
um that is a race that has been
tightening dramatically in arizona
um you know biden is currently leading
but it's
also a state that trump won by just 90
000 vote half of which came from that
county
um so you know we're awaiting about 15
percent of the ballots there are still
left to be counted
so anything could really happen so a lot
of
tension a lot of uncertainty right now
anything could happen well donald
trump's
lawyers are they're saying they're going
to file legal challenges in a number of
key states
particularly ones where donald trump is
not doing so well uh
this could really still get messy
couldn't it it absolutely could i mean
trump the trump campaign is
currently considering legal action or
has already filed lawsuits in arizona
michigan nevada pennsylvania where
uh there was a decision ahead of the
election to
extend the amount of time that they
could count votes especially these
mail-in ballots that
have been so contested um in wisconsin
where biden is up by less than one
percent which allows
trump to demand a recount if it stays
that way
um essentially this means that even if
biden backs
nevada um georgia pennsylvania which
would take him to 306 electoral votes
which is exactly the same amount of
votes that trump got in 2016.
um you know he also biden currently has
a popular vote lead of more than three
and a half million
um i mean by any measure that would be a
very decisive victory
but it could possibly deal does not
count it does not count but even if he
wins all these guests of 306 electoral
votes or more
we could still see uh it could still
take weeks before we
see an official result peter thank you
very much
that was dw's peter da thank you
well we're into a second day without a
conclusive result in the 2020 u.s
election
while there's little to back up claims
that doubt the integrity of this
election this wouldn't be the first time
the u.s boat counting process has come
under scrutiny
scrutiny and taken more than a few days
to name a winner
november 2000 republican presidential
candidate george w
bush seems to win florida but the
results are so close
that the rules demand a recount the
whole election
hangs in the balance democratic
candidate al gore
requests a manual recount in certain
counties
recounting by hand took a long time
a legal battle slowed vote counting down
and the state overshot the safe harbor
date
december 8th this allowed the bush
campaign
to ask the supreme court to stop a new
statewide recount
which it did bush was declared the
winner by a margin of just a few hundred
votes
fast forward to this november another
election without an immediate result
the established law in some states is
that counting early and
mail-in ballots can only start on
election day
and this year the corona pandemic meant
millions of people voted that way
counting all these ballots takes guess
what a long time
we don't know how long yet but that
december 8th
safe harbor deadline is starting to
become visible on the horizon
president trump has already said he
intends to use lawsuits to slow down
or stop state counts which could push
them past the safe harbor date
and make them vulnerable to challenges
his first comments after poll's close
pointed towards this he falsely said
counting votes after election day
was illegal
[Applause]
we were getting ready to win this
election frankly
we did win this election this is a major
fraud in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
his democratic opponent joe biden had
been expecting this and tried to take
the wind out of trump's sales
we knew because of the unprecedented
early vote in the mail-in vote
that was going to take a while we're
going to have to be patient
until we the hard work of tallying the
votes is finished
if undeclared states miss the safe
harbor date while there's still
no overall result the u.s congress and
supreme court
could get involved bringing back
memories of the bitterly divided 2000
contest
let's get some reaction from europe now
our brussels bureau chief alexander fun
naman
is monitoring that for us she joins us
from brussels alexandra
what do europeans make of this u.s
election
limbo well brussels the whole europe
is waiting watching holding its breaths
and when we too when we look at the
heads of eu institutions and
nato and most of eu leaders uh we have
to say they are silent they know what's
at stake right now but those politicians
who did
comment they reacted mostly with dismay
to president trump's premature
declaration of victory to his
allegations of
fraud most of them saying that they are
afraid that it could be in
constitutional crisis in the united
states
that could have international
implications
german foreign minister haikumas for
example also pointed
to the deep polarization in the u.s and
manfred weba the chairman of the
european people's party in the european
parliament said that this
polarization is a warning for europe to
take this issue
seriously transatlantic relations
alexander have been strained during
trump's presidency
you yourself covered the white house for
quite a
good chunk of that do you see any chance
of those relations improving
if trump gets a second term
if trump gets a second term then we have
to say that many people here fear
that that would be a disaster of further
damage to to the transatlantic relations
uh because of what trump did he pulled
out of the
climate agreement paris climate
agreement he pulled out of the iran
nuclear deal
but also because uh he is someone who
disrespects us respects european
institutions
international organizations so it's
really difficult to imagine
how the european union could work with
him together to tackle those
issues that matter to them how much of a
difference
would a biden presidency then make for
ties between
europe and the us what do you think
well i think that there would be a huge
difference the europeans are really
hoping that
if joe biden gets elected there will
would be
a change of the atmosphere a more
a friendlier tone between europe and the
united states
they want to see someone in the white
house who they can rely on
who is predictable who they can sit
together and
and talk about uh those issues that i
mentioned that are important to both
europe and the united states
alexander thank you very much that was
dw's alexander phenom
our brussels spirit
you